Target stock is down 15 combined Target
and Bud Light have lost around 28
billion dollars in market share and this
really does matter because it seems like
the tides are turning in the culture War
there's an article from New York mag
where these leftists are shocked to find
that conservatives and the right were
actually able to pull off a boycott and
actually set a market shift
but now we're seeing more companies
Chick-fil-A hiring a diversity equity
and inclusion VP so this stuff is
spreading plus we got a baseball player
from the I think the the Blue Jays
bending the knee and engaging a struggle
session because he supported the target
boycott
we have to talk about this stuff we've
got a lot of uh news and I think the big
story here is that last week CBS I
believe it was reported that there were
bomb threats at various Target locations